so it's almost like this character has a
mini court trial going on and they're on
the witness stand they've got this trial
attorney that's just grilling them yeah
but it's really their own voices their
own it's their from the past whatever
what their own possible that's just just
relentless yeah and and so does it break
them down
does it cause them to you know you've
seen films where someone will have a
meltdown on the witness stand is it
almost like that they're having this
mini meltdown inside themselves as the
character oh yeah I mean yeah there have
been breakdowns they've been some
extraordinary things that have happened
even to the point where it's has
frightened other people in the room with
the power of what's happening which I
could tell you about one which is
interesting where one character I drove
a a character to the point of suicide
and she was ready to kill herself and
where the other people and we'll kept
begging me to stop because they were so
frightened what she was going to do so
finally I did stop and the actress his
name was Kathy and I was talking to the
character I don't remember the
character's name so they want me to stop
slate and the way to stop is just to
address that the actor by her real name
and I said Kathy okay we're gonna stop
and she was like oh okay why why I said
well they're people who were scared I
said you okay Kathy says I'm fine why do
we stop in other words the separation
between character actor is really
profound that the character can be going
through most extraordinary emotional
experiences and the actor is fine the
actor is protected from that the actor
is experiencing it obviously because
that's happening within the actor but
what's to stop it's they're done they're
over so it's so it it's running very
deep inside the character and getting
back to a moment about Stanislavski and
all of that and going back there's the
whole history and the group theatre and
Strasbourg and Mizer all that the way I
see the work that they were doing that I
feel I'm totally in line with is that
they were always looking for how can we
get closer to the truth of the case
how can we stop pretending stop
manufacturing I think this is what the
method has done this is what's
Stanislavski was going after this is
what the Meissner tea technique is done
this is what a lot of other teachers
were there is Grotowski or viola Spolin
they're all moving towards authenticity
and what I feel I'm doing here as I've
found yet an extension of what they're
doing I feel like I've actually going
all the way back to Stanislavski I've
shifted back to the character again some
of my problems with the the method and
Stanislaw Strasburg even though I'm I am
a member of the Actors Studio both here
and in New York invited I was invited by
Harold Clurman which is cool and here I
was invited by Mark Riedel I'm a member
there and I see the work they're doing
my problem is there's a little too much
focus on acting and how the actors
behave and what I've done is I said
let's shift to the character let's take
your mind off of the acting because if
you if you're always thinking about the
acting while you're trying to be the
character there's no room for the
character's mind I want to stimulate the
character's mind the ironic thing about
this technique is as opposed to probably
all other ways of approaching acting I
think this technique the interrogation
technique is director dependence or
other dependent the actor cannot do it
by themselves because you cannot sit
there and think okay I'm gonna shut down
my actors mind and open up my characters
mind soon as you think that the actors
mine is working it has a job shut it you
can't shut your brain down the
interrogation process because it's so
powerful and overwhelming forces the
actors minded drift into the background
forces the character's mind and
personality to emerge so it needs
another person not necessarily the
director but it's good if it's the
director he's another person for that
that to happen so I feel like I'm
actually right in line was where
Stanislavski was like
shift off of the actor back to the
character I've just taken a few steps
further into a very powerful and it's
very fast it can happen in a matter of
minutes but you've seen I do humbly
believe that what I've done and what I'm
doing because this is a constant process
is I'm continuing the work started with
Stanislavski and Strasbourg and Meisner
and viola Spolin and kotovsky a lot of
these legendary explorers of the acting
process and continuingly to shift the
focus back to the character to
relinquish from the actor the
responsibility of creating or pretending
to be something and allow the actor to
experience the character that actually
lives within them now as I said before
this the challenging part of this
process is it takes two people that
director and an actor or an actor and
somebody else the actor cannot just do
it by themselves it's an engagement now
the beauty of that is it's an engagement
it is part of the acting process where
the actresses I'll be the character you
interrogate me and suddenly they're in
an improvisation which they understand
it's interesting this takes pressure off
of the actor the actor doesn't have to
have any answers at all many times I've
worked with an actor and we've been
talking about a character we go I don't
know that she think this is so you think
that I don't know I say well let's ask
the character they go great and then we
go in an interrogation may only take 30
seconds and bam the answer is out we've
got a great so the we allow the actor to
do what they want to do which is act as
to be the character an example of this
is a couple years ago I directed a play
I directed a lot of theater and hydrect
film and television director play 11
actors now 11 actually we went through a
10-week rehearsal process this way using
interrogation at first the interrogation
was in the casting process which is a
startling thing to watch and was
startling for the actors to get up there
and read for a part and the first thing
I do is I start interrogate
the character there is no preparation
there's no warning and you watch the
actors and within a second the actor
will go right back into the character
happily they don't want to be questioned
they don't want to be told what to do
they want to be the character and then
I'm I base my casting process on the
characters that are revealed inside the
actor more than their ability to read or
to perform because I'm looking for
authenticity now I've cast eleven people
this way 10-week rehearsal process and
during that process I am teaching these
actors how to interrogate besides
interrogating them as the characters I'm
teaching them how to interrogate each
other because the dangerous or not the
danger the challenges and theater
they're going to do the play every night
and one thing that's once you see the
interrogation process the ironic thing
is actors are very good at it because it
requires improvisation it requires as I
said before playing the committee
playing multiple characters and so what
if I was interrogating you I could shift
from an ally to a nemesis to a mother
figure in other words I have to be able
to do that so actors are very good at it
so I'm teaching these actors how to do
this because it's a play and I have a
problem here these actors have to do
this play every night in a film I can
interrogate an actor right before a
performance get them in exactly the
state of mind I wanted to be them and
send them in the scene and film it I'm
done I can't do that in a play every
night it's a different performance so
I'm teaching these actors how to
interrogate each other as the play is
running and this was the plan the
actually the event that was going on
backstage was far more fascinating than
what was going on on stage and I rarely
saw it because backstage the actors are
interrogating each other before every
entrance I have an entrance in five
minutes can you interrogate me they're
doing that backstage so that the actor
can come on on stage fully in character
not to have to be standing there waiting
for the cue line to come out and try to
hit an emotional state that they know
they're supposed to be they're already
in it
of the interrogation that's going on
backstage in fact there was one in one
of the actors who did a lot of
interrogation backstage would come to me
after performance you know how was
Koreans entrance huh it was great great
I tried something new
he's talking about what he was doing
backstage to send her on and wanted to
know for me how it worked so there was
this now so we had a process there with
these eleven actors they were working
together like a team helping each other
get into character deep into character
before every entrance the play by that
way was fantastic
even though the backstage I've heard was
really phenomenal but I never got to see
it I get to hear about it
you